you know i think that people want people
want to
they want to have a good job they want
to be able to put food on their table
and provide for their family
um they they they want to have a sense
of purpose
like their life counts for something and
uh i think
people have been sold different recipes
on how to how they're going to get that
and so
you know politically you know are are
you going to have somebody who's going
to give you those things
or give you the opportunity to work for
those things and invest in those things
for the people that have not seen the
campfire revival you are sitting at the
campfire right now you lit the fire for
us
hopefully you're not going to
self-immolate or burn the flag while
we're here
but you did this all just as we sat down
uh what are you doing over there at the
campfire revival on
on instagram and facebook is is that it
just just chat well i know what you're
doing so i'm asking you
i'm asking as the audience not as myself
i know what you're doing
okay so so basically you know this all
started
you know after this whole last year and
then and through the election time and
the inauguration and people are talking
about the first hundred days of the
administration
and uh you know so many of us have been
sort of like waiting and hoping for
someone else to do
something and we're waiting for this to
happen and i thought to myself as i'm
sitting in my backyard
cooped up in uh california where you're
where you're
base basically and under house arrest
and lockdown uh at the time
wait a minute what's our plan what
what's
what kind of a 100-day plan could i be a
part of
that's going to actually promote the
positive change rather than just
complaining about the things that i
don't like to see and i said you know
what
i don't know the best plan but i'm going
to start a plan and it's going to be i'm
going to sit in my
backyard for 100 days in a row and build
a campfire
and i'm going to invite other people to
join me as we pray
as we worship god and as we begin to
learn what made america the freest
strongest most prosperous nation in the
world
uh and and we found that on facebook
live we'd have 15 to 20
000 people every single night joining
and the comments were flying
and people made it a destination every
night because they found hope
and they found something for them to to
talk about with their kids
and we did that for 100 days called it
the american campfire revival
and it's all about that inside out
strategy that bottom up strategy
that our founders understood and that i
think is going to be the solution to
getting us back to where we want to go
yeah what else are you working on right
now you're going to be traveling again
and spreading the word and getting out
there i mean you're here in cali
they are we are opening up apparently at
some point
yeah that's that that's right well uh i
am working on quite a few things this
american campfire revival has been uh
just kind of a surprise joy for me to do
although all of my wardrobe smells like
smoke and my wife is
tired of it uh i'm roasting like a
marshmallow as we speak
uh my back is my backside is turning
golden brown you just
see it nice nice and um
we're gonna we're gonna continue this
and i'm about to start uh
another 40 days of the american campfire
revival
speaking about family covenants and then
community covenants church covenants and
civil government covenants
that kind of all weave together to to
form kind of this this kevlar fabric
that i believe will resist
the the the darts of tyranny and
totalitarianism
um in fact uh this is something i wanted
to show you yeah this is a pledge that i
kind of modeled
after the declaration of independence
called our pledge to renew the american
covenant
and it's what we can affirm together as
families and as individuals
to get back to these these values and
and we've signed it here
and i'm hoping people hang this in their
wall and talk about it as a family
and with their neighbors and then we
have some live events around the country
where we gather in fields and fields and
farms oh whoa
you didn't just no that's all right
we're good
we're good but if you dropped the whole
covenant in the fire just then that that
would
it we're still good and uh and and
gather around bonfires and sing
and pray and talk about what really
matters and uh if we have one here in
california
i'll make sure that uh i invite you i'd
love to have you come i'd love to come
for a second i thought newsom was about
to try to take you out i thought he you
know because he's got these
snipers out there people are in the
backyard having fun with an american
flag jeez
that's actually the first time that's
happened uh so uh
i think if you see any smoke coming from
behind me you let me know okay yeah yeah
i hope you have insurance for this
program
uh wait so give me some of the give me
two or three of the uh
of the uh not edicts of the of the
principles that are on the
on the documentary yeah that's it um
let's see
uh boy here we go uh we promise to each
other as a family
to provide for one as long as we live
as commanded in scripture uh there's so
many others uh we commit to living
peacefully to obey the laws of the land
and and working to elect uh godly
trustworthy leaders who will not abuse
their limited power as our public
servants and distort our constitution
so we talk about the the civic realm and
also the family realm
and also uh the uh the the community
realm
and and you know all of it really begins
with with self-government right
um i think this is important i think
people would find this interesting
uh when we talk about government we're
usually talking about them you know like
out there or up there we're talking
about
government and what they're doing but in
in our country our founders understood
that
that kind of government will be terrible
totalitarian government
unless we
lay the foundation of self-government
and if we govern ourselves
according to the the rules of right
right like it's not about left or right
it's about up or down and and if we go
up to the
to heaven's rules of right then
we don't need the government with the
big stick to beat us back
into civility we've already got that we
got that
individually we got it in our families
we got it in our communities and
government can stay limited and small
and people have freedom
and so that's really the the essence the
most
powerful culture transforming force in
the world
is the self-governing person who
loves god and loves their neighbor
that's what our founders believed and
that's what i'm trying
to communicate to people which one do
you think is harder for your
old hollywood friends to swallow the the
belief part
or your feelings about government part
because they're probably not thrilled
with either
you mean government being limited yeah
well that you believe in small
government in the constitution that
america is good you know that
that sort of stuff is or the belief part
is that harder for them to swallow
oh boy um i don't know
you know it's all so so tied together um
but actually
i think that uh
it's interesting you said that small
government and that america is good
um you know the principles radical is
bounded on is
are absolutely good the framework is
genius it's beautiful but
it depends on personal self-government
all of our founders told us that and the
truth is i'm actually for
big government but it's not what you
think it's big self-government
it's big family government and once we
take care of that
we we don't need a big police force
because we're doing the right thing
at the friend and family level i think a
lot of people are watching this going
what are you two fools still doing
in california i mean at this at this
point for you is it is it just the
weather i mean you could be doing this
in florida
or calif uh florida or texas or
tennessee
yeah yeah that's true and i certainly
understand why people are moving out of
here
they're they're getting out of here like
rats jumping off of a ship uh because
we're sinking economically
and uh and and politically however
uh i'm all about revival look at my
shirt american campfire revival revival
right so that means like putting life
back into things
again things that are flatlining and
dying
reviving them um i think that can happen
anywhere i think it can happen in my
marriage
if my marriage is flatlining i think it
can happen uh in my family
my community i think it can happen in
our state and so i'm
hoping and praying that that ameri that
america and and starting with california
begins to see a renewal a revival and a
resurgence
of the kind of stuff that will cause
human flourishing
uh not human decay what do you think we
can do in this crazy state i mean
you know i'm i'm hanging on by a thread
man
i i know i hear you i'm here well i'm
starting with a campfire
all right all right fair enough i'm all
right that's it i'm coming i'm coming to
the campfire
and i'm listening to you and i'm
listening to others
and uh and i believe that there are
people with more brilliant ideas than i
have
that uh are are gonna are gonna help
move us in the right direction
and uh and i continue to pray for them
do you find that people across the
country when you're traveling
regardless of whether you're red or blue
or any of that stuff that people
are pretty much the same uh-oh uh-oh
what's going on behind you now
um the people are pretty much the same
what do you mean like uh
regardless of whether they're ready if
you can really get to them that the
stuff that you're talking about
is sort of the stuff that they really
believe some of them just don't know it
maybe
you know i think that people wanna
people wanna they wanna have a good job
they wanna be able to put food on their
table and provide for their family
um they they they wanna have a sense of
purpose
like their life counts for something and
uh i think people have been
sold different recipes on how to
how they're gonna get that and so you
know politically
uh you know are are you gonna have
somebody who's going to give you those
things
or give you the opportunity to work for
those things and invest in those things
uh that that's that that's one aspect of
it
but i think at the end of the day if
we're talking about values
you know i've got friends who are on the
other side of the aisle
and uh you know they want the same
things that i want
i i want an opportunity to to provide
for my family i want an
opportunity to be able to speak the
truth and not be censored for it
i want an opportunity to to pursue
happiness and
and not be restricted and controlled and
thrown into a cage
because somebody disagrees with me and
i i think there's there's a very
specific way to go about that
and that's what i'm trying to promote if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell